so hi everyone I'm by looting I'm from
the dinner management money exploration
team and Microsoft Research so our group
mostly work on data based delivery
systems and dinner manage staff and
today I'm going to talk about our
project on how to automatically index in
data base for a your DB so this is joint
work with my colleagues and my
passengers so illnesses are important
data structure for database systems
where you can help navigate the data
efficiently so that you can execute the
chorus efficiently but creating the
right set of illnesses for given
workload is a very challenging task
because it requires you to understand
the database internals and also
understand like how the workload look
like for this particular database so the
goal of this project is how can we
automatically manage and create the
illnesses for millions of the databases
in a ODB now let's take a look at like
how your works in this moment like
without the automatically tuning on work
we're doing so currently there is an
expert who take who look at the database
and analyze what is the workload of the
database and then expert user index
changing to to come up with the state of
illnesses as the index recommendation
but it's not down here because the
expert need to analyze the
recommendations for milk to and do some
trial and error in terms of like does
this recommendation make sense and what
will be the best Sailor Venus is to
create for this database and then the
expert finalized the indices to create
for this database now the question is
that you may ask is that if we already
have the index tuned in to why do we
still haven't automate the whole process
now the issue or the Challenger is the
index tune into recommends the
Englishness based on the estimated cost
of the date of the in the of the benefit
provided by the state of illnesses
because it hasn't like without creating
the scene as he doesn't know like how
much really improvement you will help
for this queries but sometimes like
estimate
to improve the chorus but it turns out
to make the car even worse so in this
case why we need an expert
human-in-the-loop who sort of automate
this process to sort of analyze its
process so given our goal is to automate
this process for LOD B what are the new
opportunities here now in the cloud we
have the ability to observe the
aggregated statistics from the execution
of the database as they are running in
the cloud like the statistics including
like how the index have changed over
time what are the query plans what are
the estimated cost in true execution
cost of the query now the challenge here
is that like given the wheels of such
are rich data how do we actually
leverage its estate how to get some
insights to help the ultimate in this
process now currently we have been
looking in two directions in how to
leverage such data one direction is like
after we create the indexes and SIOC
some query becomes more expensive than
before how do we remedy such a situation
based on the execution history of the
database now the second direction is
that if we like just react when the
query requests that's probably already
too late because the illness's has
already been created now what is the
even more helpful is that can we prevent
creating such illnesses that will lead
to the queries to become more expensive
in this work about looking at some of
the sting district of gnarling
techniques to help with the prediction I
think that's about it
if you have any questions or if you are
interested in this topic a place will
come to talk to me offline as well
[Applause]
you